As you can imagine, since data science is being deployed
in such a wide range of fields, data scientists use
many different tools, depending on the task at hand. One
of the most versatile and ubiquitous is a Python package called
Pandas, which we'll use in order to handle and manipulate
data during this course. You might wonder why we'll be using
Pandas, as opposed to another tool. Pandas allows us to
structure and manipulate our data in ways that are particularly well-suited
for data analysis. If you happen to be familiar with the scripting language, R,
Pandas takes a lot of the best elements from R and implements them in Python.